d'ailleurs qui est toujours en train de
demander de l'oseille à droite à gauche
vous est ce que vous le faites julie non
non
bah j'ai vite mais vous lui régis
j'évite serait la vraie faut le rendre
on aime bien demandé moi-même pas là by
ap ap hm à castaldi
tu as well alors je demande tout le
temps l'argent à tout le monde des
proches tout le monde parce qu'en fait
j'ai lu dans l'express notamment
l'article 65 % des dettes ne sont pas
remboursés si durement de son euro au
pire au pire mais j'aurais gagné
j'aurais gagné 45 euros à faire payer
même quand je vous êtes producteur
mais voilà je viens sur un petit peu
large mais bâclé dans les combes
c'est comme ça j'en dois pas mal à
droite à gauche mais mais 250 aussi par
exemple il ya des gens de ma famille des
amis proches qui a déjà prêté de
l'argent à gagner qu'à quelqu'un de
l'est qui lui l'a jamais revu acquis à
benjamin benjamin qui demandent toujours
2 euros par ci par là pour interpeller
alors prêté serment ça existe pas ces
données 2 euros lequel fait 40 centimes
benjamin 50 euros non ouais mais j'ai
une mission à tournus c'est un peu court
l'algérien sur moi tabac 50 euros et
alors ils vont ça ne m'arrive vous avez
ce jeune femme qui était chroniqueuse
ici nadège beausson diagne et la meuf
elle s'en souvient la mère légale
un gros à la sortie le vine la sortie le
bail du genre à traumatisme la neige
toujours moi ce que j'aime beaucoup
nadège ça fait quatre ans qu'on l'a pas
vu tous les soirs à ce coup sec mme
aubry la nage tu me dois encore mais 40
balles tirées des bâtonnets la parole
que 3 des couacs ont bien là combien on
peut se dit pas mais conséquente
oui beaucoup beaucoup en ont marre est
énorme et attendait la lampe à la part
dans un dossier là s'arrête quoi j'ai
une montant ras jdir un talent c'est
vrai c'est pas un prêt là vous êtes des
tares et je considère que c'est un don
parce que c'est toujours à des gens
insolvables donc très bien en tout cas
c'est tout à votre honneur excepté bravo
je savais pas que j'allais avoir des
problèmes avec cette équipe moi j'avais
une nouvelle personne à taxer est-ce que
vous avez déjà trouvé un billet par
terre et vous l'avez pris ouais ouais
ouais
les prix directs savaient pas j'ai un
peu mal mais j'ai regardé regarde
toujours apeurés je laissais style c'est
un billet non une pièce où vous j'ai
rendu un portefeuille avec beaucoup
d'argent dedans non trouvée au jardin
des plantes quand j'étais étudiant à
jussieu c'était des francs encore
assurée mille francs 150 euros l'heure
on ne sait pas cependant que c'est pas
de la route les deux ça leur vision du
jeu est rendu ici à côté du billet et
personne voilà c'est ça oui non mais
c'est sûr sur le billet y avait marqué
banon mais on peut penser par weepu
souvent dans les couloirs du canal
factory le studio ici il ya des billets
ouais alors on les proue mais en fait
c'est vous qui les cachets qui les fait
tomber comme ça pour tester l'honnêteté
des meneaux
il est content c'est vrai j'ai pris un
jour c'est pas toi dans ma poche j'ai
trouvé un jour dans ma poche quand vous
l'avez fait remarquer j'avais la honte
ces théories n'est pas un gros billet
non plus annoncé jamais sur les
messieurs non moi j'étais un joli geste
muse des plus jeunes un budget vous oui
j'avais trouvé un portefeuille de
dossiers mais les cartes de crédit plane
carte vitale tout ça donc c'est toujours
pénible de les faire refaire il y avait
je sais plus je crois l'époque 100 euros
donc j'ai pris l'argent ce qui le le le
enfin parce que je pris du temps sur moi
pour avance mais j'ai rapporté le
portefeuille pour les personnes nées par
guerre toutes les cartes et tout ça
c'est dégueulasse parce qu'il ya le long
du mec qui a adressé ne m'en rends lui
c'est sous viendraient s'y attend sa
personne sur radio gens at il gardé il
c'est pas moi qui le pense est quelqu'un
d'autre donc ça en tant qu il soit dans
ma poche
d'ailleurs le nom vous avez déjà trop va
te croire de boulettes
on dirait mais vous vous avez déjà
trouvé de quelque chose de l'argent m'a
amené à mon portefeuille non avait
oublié avec mon sac et mon portable à
marseille
ouais j'ai appelé l'opérateur poursuivre
le portail le portail le portable
jusqu'à parler j'ai suivi la voiture qui
avait pris mon sac
ouais jusqu'à paris et ensuite comme ça
à bobine et m'a appelé et m'a dit que la
personne n'avait laissé que mais c'est
rien passionnant
mais là qu'est ce qu'elle m'a dit sans
rigoler connaissais pas comme ça les
deux ça va mal ou pas du tout sujet jugé
la cei et la guerre et de charisme et
une amie à moi qui a trouvé 37000 euros
grâce au pied d'un restaurant kouassi
dans le 16ème arrondissement près de la
porte de saint cloud près d'ici là là là
là là
la responsable a gérant du restaurant
avait fermé le rideau de fer il était 3
4 3 heures du matin la presse la recette
de la semaine avait fermé le fait est
posée l'enveloppent parterre contre le
mur en attendant qu'elle ferme le rideau
elle est partie comme ça mais ma copine
sortait elle deux heures après et est
tombé sur une enveloppe elle ses doutes
et ses restaurants elle a rapporté et
depuis elle peut manger à vis dans le
restaurant abuse pas mais elle y
retourne régulièrement ça c'est une
belle histoire mais naïve qu'elle était
une histoire un peu pourri
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quel est le pire truc de khadda que vous
ayez fait déjà fait des trucs de radars
régis que vous êtes rabadan non
franchement round quand vous invitez
tous les polonais a vraiment mais comme
ça bon ça sert à ça la race et saint
brès et inviter les coop messerer
inviter les amis déjà mais la loi
scellier jamais c'est une fois par an on
va par la rentrée une fois par où nous
remettre un peu voulait pas que je
sortirai voulais pas me sortir non pas
mal non c'est trop tôt
[Musique]
j'adore je vous êtes radine n'ont pas
trop beau si vous dépensez tout bah
ouais vous avez déjà fait un truc de
radin qui a ramené la barre là bas on va
parler de toi pas le dorado web
mettez-vous là je raconte des dossiers
si c'est moi là bas a dit propos raconté
moi c'est pas vraiment radin c'est plus
un souci d'économie je fais pipi sous la
douche
j'admets parce que j'ai lu un rapport
international caisse à tout vent il fait
interdits sous la douche en se douchant
on économiserait des tonnes et des
tonnes mais des milliers de tonnes d'eau
sur la planète a besoin et que ce serait
un geste social jour depuis j'ai gardé
l'habitude la commission qui le font je
parie que vous serez parfois moi je
reçois des cadeaux presse et je les
offre à mes parents mais je redis que je
les achetais donc là c'est la deuxième
chose c'est parfois lors d'un dîner avec
une prétendante la première fois
d'offres de falla tu payes le dîner qui
a comme très tendance assez récent c'est
qui la dernière luce auger
mais si la première fois d'offres
naturel est également encore est la
deuxième fois je suis pro l'égalité
hommes femmes ont fait moitié moitié et
pour montrer mon élan de générosité
je lui prends les boissons en plus est
là elle m'a fait la gueule comme c'est
pas possible elle est repartie en ait
trop la même pas voulu monter sur ma
trottinette en tout cas vos trois votes
soirée fait rêver quand j'ai été radin
mais j'ai beaucoup changé
plus jeune j'ai offert à ma compagne de
l'époque un tour d'europe des abribus
[Musique]
je n'avais pas d'argent et je lui ai dit
chérie on part en vacances pendant un
mois et on a fait tous les abribus en
suisse italie allemagne pays bas
belgique on alors là elle vous attrape
au vol dormait sous les abribus tous les
quatre jours une douche ouais c'est pas
ça doit être sympa c'est toi j'en ai
honte à merci